So now that you know how to support the view
port meta, let's poke around in the developer tools to
see what we need to do to fix this page.
Now, the biggest problem here is that the page has
a fixed column width. If I resize the window, you'll
notice the column of text doesn't actually change size, just
margin position. As we mouse around the elements inside the
dev tools, we can pretty quickly find, the first offending element.
This page element here actually has a width set
on it. Let's disable that and see what happens. Well,
it certainly changed things, but I don't think that
it actually improved things very much. Let's keep digging inside
the content and see what we can find. This
wrapper element has a width of 100% already. Which is
good. It means that it's not preventing us from
resizing. But this content element does have a width set
in pixels. Let's disable that. Now as we resize
the page our content is fine but the sidebar is
appearing and disappearing. Sure enough, it has a width set.
If we set its width as a percentage also, now
we're resizing a little bit better. So now let's
go back up to the page, and let's try giving
it a width but let's give it a width in
view port units instead, now our only remaining problem seems
to be that the header is actually not resizing as
we want it to let's go take a look at
the header image again. The image has a max width
set, but not just a width. So, let's set its width.
And now, everything seems to be resizing well. Now, this isn't perfect,
but all that I really wanted to get at was that as you
try to transition pages from fixed layout to fluid layout, The core
things to look for, are fixed pixel sizes and lack of percentage resize.